et série tpm puce serait pas la tp sont
la régie la régie c'est depuis huit ans
il ya eu 8526 licenciement c'est pas
vrai franchement on a on a toujours les
mêmes les clips regarder david il est là
depuis le début pour david tout le monde
est là depuis le début tous les gars
auraient givré à tous les cadreurs et
tous et ils font partie de l'aventuré et
c'est vrai que une compile de la région
restera penalty obligatoire ce soir
regardez la régie normand toutes les
émissions
il ya un truc qui merde mais ses sacres
aux clients des missions dernier il ya
des personnes en régie qui sont là en
emploi précaire ne demandez rien aux
gens de la régie c'est vraiment mais je
sais dans cette émission ne compter que
sur vous même mais tu cm c'est aussi et
surtout la passion du jeu de mots sport
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la régie boudineau l'oreillette ces bons
ces cartes ne les croyez jamais parce
que si décalé comme beaucoup la
chanteuse shy'm avec site et ou de dieu
[Musique]
à chaque personne que je sauterai de
parler en régie me disent on n'a pas
attendez on le cherche
je sais pas qui met la musique mais je
vais aller en régie et ça va chier des
bulles tahrir mégafusion sinon tu
écoutes en plein essor voilà vous savez
les sons qui partent pas battus merci
magie des lieux tombera c'est toujours
la personne
la raison la régie oui et valérie dire
avoir des charges que vous bousculez
vraiment le leur et qu'ils soient hyper
réactif et que parfois la technique bas
ça prend un tout petit peu de temps au
lieu de un dixième de seconde
non c'est vrai qu'avec la régie atp peut
travailler dans n'importe quelle région
du monde n'a jamais connu une fusée ça
c'est le cas il peut faire décoller une
filière bois way
excuse moi vous bouffez pendant là il
est en train de se faire une clémentine